IGNACIO MONEREO: Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
I think I know half
of the audience here.
So please raise your hand
if you already know me,
because it's kind of like, OK.
Perfect this is the
perfect case scenario
where you have a friendly
audience with you.
So please laugh
with all my jokes.
And make very, very
simple questions.
So for those who don't
know me, welcome.
My name is Ignacio, or Nacho.
I am in the Google Play team,
business development manager.
I'm based in London
and I'm working
with MOBA game developers.
So today we're going
to talk about lifetime.
So thanks a lot for
coming because I
know there's very
high competition,
very tough competition,
and very good sessions
at this very same time.
I think my colleagues
are doing a great job,
so the fact that
you're here, I'll
try to make the most
out of the session.
And the session is going
to last for 25 minutes
and it's going to be recorded.
So you can watch it later on.
This is the agenda
and we're just
going to cover some points.
And I don't have the
answer to the lifetime
value on the equation.
And let's say that the
million dollar question, which
is how we make money, but I
hope that the session today will
help you to kind of like
understand this topic.
And hopefully take some
decisions in the future.
And it's useful for you.
So the first question is
like, why LTV and why everyone
is talking about lifetime value.
So I'm not going to
spend too much time.
I think we all know
that these days
everyone is talking
about lifetime
value for a couple of reasons.
First, well mostly
the technology
is enabling to
track more things,
and we can
[INAUDIBLE] much more,
more behaviors, rather
than just installs.
We also see that
in game [INAUDIBLE]
analytics and it's
becoming more relevant.
And probably you have
all data analysts
within your team
or your company.
But also like the
whole ecosystem,
that graph over there, we've
seen it a number of times,
already, where revenues
and usage are increasing.
But install seems
to be stagnating,
or at least stabilizing,
which means that we need
to make more out of our users.
And then we need to think
about other metrics.
Maybe metrics that--
before they didn't
have so much relevance, such as
like long-term retentions, day
90 or day 180.
They become more relevant
nowadays, and also,
lifetime value.
So just to get on the
same page, let's think
about what lifetime value is.
Because I think we all
agree that lifetime value
is kind of like the
expected revenues
that our users are
going to generate
in the lifetime of the game.
However, we do not agree
in many other things.
For example, the way to
calculate lifetime value,
nobody agrees.
Everyone has their
own custom way,
and probably it's
actually right.
So that's one thing that we
need to take into account when
we are talking to someone
about lifetime value.
It might be very different
from your calculation.
A couple of other things.
So for example, we
have a crystal ball
illustrating this is
light, which means that we
are predicting the future.
And predicting the future
means that we are not
going to be accurate.
This is not an accurate
science, and therefore, we
need to think about in terms
of like what is my error
or interval of confidence.
And therefore,
what is going to be
the range of my lifetime value?
And then two last things,
which would be dynamic metric.
So my lifetime value
changes over time.
And this we've seen it, not
only with external factors--
let's imagine that we have
a competitor launching
a similar game.
And then, all of the
sudden, my users fly.
But also, internally, we can
affect this lifetime value by,
I don't know, releasing
new functionalities
or new live ops, which
are going to help
to increase it, hopefully.
And then, last one is a metric.
So it doesn't mean that by
having a very high lifetime
value, you're going
to have a string
and competitive
advantage over the rest.
And therefore, we
need to think about it
like this is just a
useful metric that
is going to help us.
So what are the usages?
So the first--
I think its clear, right?
If we understand
the lifetime value,
we can understand,
what are the costs?
And therefore, we
can think about
what is profitability
for every user?
And this is very much
related to user acquisition
and is being used
most of the times
in terms of driving campaigns or
UA campaigns, where we actually
know how much are
we going to spend,
or at least what is our limit
for expenditure in campaigns.
However, two other ideas--
which my conversations
with developers,
they haven't been
used that much--
would be to think about lifetime
value also for live ops.
So when we release a new
functionality, or new feature
within the game, these might
have an impact in engagement,
but also in monetization.
So sometimes we might
see that the increase
in the game in engagement
might offset the increase
or [INAUDIBLE] decrease
in monetization.
So the net effect of
that functionality
is actually zero
for lifetime value.
So you can think
about it this way.
Also, for pipeline,
thinking about new games,
if we start looking at this
data from the very beginning,
and we have enough data, we
can think about a method,
or take it into
consideration, these metrics
by designing a game.
So once we have these, what
I've done is to classify.
I spoke-- and I'm talking
about popular ways, here--
because I spoke to many of you,
actually, who are sitting here,
and I want to
thank, at this point
for participating
in these interviews
that I run for the
last couple of months.
And basically, I was
asking developers
who are working on a
regular basis, what
are the ways that they are
calculating lifetime value?
And what we are going to
do, is just like basically,
classify these ways.
Share some of these insights
that you, basically,
shared with us, and
try to figure out
which ways might be more
relevant or more interesting
for your actual game.
So the first thing
is one common thing
that we see in the lifetime
value is that either we
are talking about retention, or
lifetime, a lifetime variable,
or we are talking about
a monetization variable,
in this case.
But when it comes to lifetime,
we, again, do not agree.
Because if you think about
retention, many of you
might take retention as the
classic retention, right?
However, some developers
that were talking to me
and they're saying, well, in
my game, it makes more sense,
you can see the
rolling retentions,
or range retentions.
Because they are episodes and
I'm launching a new season,
things like that, for example.
Or daily versus hourly.
Why, in a casual game, it
might not make sense, actually,
to look at daily retention,
but hourly retention,
because that's when we are
losing the users very, very
fast.
Also, collect daily rewards
versus play a battle.
As of today, retention is
defined by opening the app.
But what about-- there's a
big difference between I'm
opening the app just to
collect a daily reward,
or actually playing a battle.
The same stands
for monetization.
Most of the time it's
our DAU RPPU, or RPPU,
but in this case, also, how
do you calculate the ARPDAU
is going to make a difference.
Am I taking the last week
or the last three months,
because it might
have a difference.
So when I am talking
to developers,
and I'm asking them
about lifetime value,
I'm going to have all these
things into consideration.
And it would be interesting
for you to think,
before you're calculating it.
Another common thing that most
developers have is the period.
And this is interesting
because it depends a lot.
It depends in a
couple of metrics.
How are we going to
calculate the period?
Like the lifetime
value, is it going
to be for 90, 180 days, one
year, or even like five years.
It might depend a lot
in some key factors.
So out of those
conversations, we
realize that things
like, for example, type
of the game, which
makes sense, like,
if it is a hardcore or casual.
I might look at
longer lifetime values
if it is a hardcore game, the
business model that I'm using,
the stage of the company, and it
all comes down to the funding.
So do I need to recover
the investment in 90 days,
or do I need to recover
it in maybe 365?
So these things are
also quite interesting
because every company
they calculate it
in a different way, depending
on some of these aspects.
There are more
aspects, by the way,
but these are the ones that
I just wanted to highlight.
So let's think about then
how we classify all the ways
that developers, nowadays,
are estimating lifetime value.
So I just put an axis there,
on the left axis, "complexity."
And then "accuracy," because I'm
assuming that the more complex
you go, the more accurate
you're going to be.
That's a priori because we
can see that, sometimes, you
can go as complex as you
want, and then accuracy
might not increase.
But let's assume
that the first one
would be very simple, historical
averages, or benchmarks.
That could be an easy way
to estimate lifetime value.
Then we would see simple
predictive models, a little bit
more advanced predictive models,
and then, well, the super hyper
advanced predictive models--
I'm not going to cover them
because they're usually
involving like
behavioral patterns.
They are involving specific
things to the game.
So if we look at the
three first models,
the first one is quite easy.
And talking to you, we are not
even looking at predictive.
We're looking at our historical
data, if we have the data,
and maybe just assessing the
RPPU of the last 180 days,
if my game has been released
six months ago, was x amount.
And I can basically estimate
with a new user at day three,
is generating 70%, and
then I will just project.
And 100% would be at day 180.
That's very simple
and, to be honest,
has some pros, which is
like very easy to estimate.
It has also, some--
well, enables quick decisions
at very early stages.
But on the other hand,
it's not very precise,
and the averages might kind
of like bias these results.
But wait, if you don't have
data, most developers, what
they are doing,
then it's looking
at benchmarks or
maybe similar games
that you have in your portfolio.
And then you say, well,
in my previous game,
I was generating x amount.
So what is the
simple predictive?
So when we talk about
simple predictive models,
we see two models
which are quite used.
The first one is the
kind like the top
down, because we are
looking at all users.
And then we are just going
to estimate the lifetime
value with this formula.
You've probably seen
it like in some places.
And we are projecting
the retention,
which is the typical
curve, survival curve.
And then we look at, well,
at day 180, in this case,
the retention is only 5%.
So on average, nine days per
user, are going to use my app.
If I multiply this
by the ARPDAU,
then I can have in this case
$0.45 would be the retention--
the lifetime value expectation
for this particular segment
of users.
A couple of pros.
Relatively easy to calculate.
There's a number of spreadsheets
online that you can download.
And then the cons are it's
not very accurate, again,
because we're taking
segments, and it depends.
From conversations that we
have, the source of traffic
might vary a lot
and might depend--
the retention might
change, quite drastically.
And then last one.
ARPDAU usually
improves with life--
with the life of the game,
because my users more loyal,
the ones that pay, they
tend to stay longer.
So my ARPDAU will improve.
So let's look then at what about
if I look only at paying users.
This is the bottoms
of the model, which
is kind of like some model
that also many developers are
looking at.
And it's basically
projecting the RPPUs,
so the average revenue
per paying users.
In this case, we use a curve,
which is a logarithmic one,
and we can project very similar
case, that at day three, just
the spending, I'm getting $30--
sorry, $0.30, I wish $30--
and $0.45 at the end of the
period, which is day 180.
A couple of pros, in this case.
So again, relatively
easy to calculate.
And we have also, that usually
the number, the percentage
of conversions, it's
relatively stable,
and we can see that it's
going to be like 1.5% or 2%
of users paying.
And the cons is usually
this model, what I heard,
is that it works well, when
you have a game that most
of monetization comes up front.
But some of the hardcore
games or strategy
games that you might
have longer monetization
or the monetization
starts later,
that curve might be
difficult to fit.
So let's move to the
advanced predictive models.
So what means advance?
Well, notice that
the crystal ball
is getting more sophisticated.
We're using like
historical data and we
are trying to predict
individual lifetime
value in a probabilistic way.
So it has some pros and cons.
In this case, too.
Whoops.
So the first one is,
obviously, we kind of
get an estimate at an individual
level, which is very useful.
It's usually more accurate.
And the cons are we need
extensive user data.
And especially we need to have
the resources and capabilities
to interpret these
data and execute
based on this insight,
which is very interesting.
And why do we need
predictive models?
Well, let me just
illustrate with a very, very
simple example.
We have two users
download the app.
Both of them have sunglasses
but it's not related in any way.
And they start buying
some gems, so you
can see Rick is a heavy buyer.
And then Gabby, it is a more
constant, but less purchases.
So if we look at certain models,
or if we look at the past,
we can think that Rick, at
this stage, if you look forward
to 180 days, would be
more valuable than Gabby.
However, many of these
probabilistic models
tell us, that indeed, Gabby is
more likely to make a purchase.
OK.
You might not like--
why is that?
And how is that?
How do we do that?
Well, I'm not going to talk
about any model, in particular,
but I'm--
sorry, I'm going to talk
about one model in particular.
I'm not going to recommend it
because I'm not getting any--
it's an open source model.
But this is one model that
we are actually looking here
at Google many times.
It's called the Buy
Till You Die model.
It's open source.
It's backed by academia and
by some Wharton researchers.
It's based on these
two models, which
is the [INAUDIBLE]
and the BGNB model.
And I kind of like--
I recommend you to have a look,
because it's quite simple,
and it might help you in
this, if you're thinking
about a predictive model.
So it's based on two sub models.
One is actually looking
at the likelihood
of making a transaction.
And the other one would
be looking at the value,
like what is going to be the
future average or the value
of those transactions.
So just to illustrate
how it works,
I'm going to use
the same example.
So we have Rick.
Rick bought a lot of
times, and the likelihood
of making a transaction is
based on two variables, which
is recency, so we are assuming
that the most recent that you
did a transaction
is, the more likely
that you're going
to make another one.
And then the frequency, which
is like how many times did you
buy.
So we are assuming,
basically, that a user that
buys a lot, during a
long period of time,
is going to be more likely
that he's going to buy again.
So Rick bought a lot, but
only like in the first five
days, which means that then,
he's probably very like you
could see the colors.
And he's in the dark,
dark blue, which
means like very likely he's
not going to buy again.
However, if we look at Gabby,
she bought very, very little.
And then we can see
that, in this case,
the likelihood of buying--
and this is, again,
this is a model
that is done based on research,
and empirically, also.
We can see that she's
also buying-- she's
going to be more likely to buy.
So what can we get out
of these type of models?
So most of the
times, we get first,
the probability of being alive.
So at a certain point of time,
looking forward, we can see,
OK, this user is going
to buy again or not.
So the number of
transactions that this person
is going to make, this user.
The expected
average order value,
so how much he's going to spend.
And finally, the expected
user LTV, which is,
in the end-- it's the product
of all the other things.
So just taking these
models as an example,
what would be the
pros and the cons?
So first, the pros.
Again, we have individual
lifetime value,
which is interesting.
It's open source.
You can download
the Python Package
and you can start by today.
And it's backed by
academia, and empirically.
And also, can be used
for other purposes.
I think this is interesting,
because some people are saying,
well, you're only
taking purchases,
but we can think about
also, some events.
Like, for example, I
don't know, like level 1,
you could even consider that
and estimate the likelihood
of playing other levels.
On the cons, what do we find?
Well, as I said before, it
works within our purchases
as of today.
If we think about
advertising, it
would be a little
bit more challenging
because of the number of events
that this is registering.
And it requires
significant amount of data.
OK.
So this would be the model,
so which one is the best?
So again, it's quite
hard because every model
has it's pros and cons.
I would say that,
personally, I would
try to look at predictive
models, whenever it's possible.
There's many of them.
This-- the one that I
explained is just one of them.
But there's others
that could be useful.
And I'll try to look
at these, whenever
we have these other key
points into consideration.
So what is the current
situation of the game?
Have we launched it a while
ago and we have the data?
What is the private [INAUDIBLE]
model that we're looking?
The type of game?
And finally, do we-- if we
have this information, about
individual lifetime
value, can we
do actually something with it?
Or we're just going
to let it there
and we actually do
not have resources,
because we need to do
something else, right.
So is that all?
Well, actually, when talking
about lifetime value,
there's other things that people
are considering, developers.
So most of it at first
is most of developers
they are looking at net
LTV and profitability,
rather than gross LTV.
So they are already
subtracting some of the cost.
Then, the second one,
if you are looking
at very long-term lifetime
values, like 180 days,
farther, or beyond, you
might think about maybe
looking at discounting it.
Then, business models.
Many of you are using
two business models
at the same time, in-app
purchases and advertising.
So one good way to think
about how would you
integrate both of them, and you
would look at all your users
from both business
models at the same time.
And then, lastly, we
see a general trend
in the business-- in the
mobile gaming industry,
a lot of multiplayer online
games that might need, indeed,
to assign some monetary
value to those users
that they generate
some liquidity.
You don't want to find yourself
playing against a board
again and again and again over.
And if you think about
other things-- so virality
has a very, very
important function in UA,
but it a priori doesn't
affect the lifetime value,
because you're augmenting
the equity of players,
and then putting that
example over there.
But it shouldn't affect
the overall lifetime value,
because you're just
adding new users.
The equity of
those paying users,
it's still is very important
from a UA perspective,
because you're bringing in
another user with that user
that you acquire.
And then last two things would
be frequency of calculations.
So how frequent are
you calculating?
I wouldn't recommend
daily, but I
would say like,
depending on the game,
if you're constantly
updating, so think about this.
And then, lastly, the segments
on the cohort analysis.
The first one would be
top versus lower spenders.
This is a typical one.
Some developers are looking
at geographies, obviously,
and then traffic sources.
Those would be the
most typical ones.
But there might be others that
you're currently overlooking.
So with this-- so what are
the tips and best practices?
So there are some
tips to improve.
I asked many of the
developers, what would
you do to improve the
LTV calculation, right?
So the first one is forget
about vanity metrics,
that they are not
used in the end.
I put downloads, but sometimes,
because all registered users,
we might argue this.
But in the end, you
want to care only
about those metrics that
are relevant for an LTV
calculation, in this case.
For example, active users, cost
of new customers, revenues,
and profit.
The plan, thirdly.
It's super important to
try to plan in advance,
rather than just going reactive
and trying to maybe delete
events that they are not
used in your daily decisions.
Integrity of data,
super important.
We need to think about
how we have integrity,
like data that is real
from the very first day.
And then, lastly, is
making trade offs.
So if we don't have enough data
to actually take a decision,
we might have to think
about how we extract
those whales or those users
that-- my heaviest spenders
that might bias my sample.
So conclusion, if
you reach to here,
five things that I
want to remember.
Like five is a lot, but--
so the first one is LTV has
many usages, as of today it's
very much useful for you.
But you can think about also
from a live ops perspective
to decide whether a new
functionality or feature is
going to be useful.
Then we can think about also
that it's not an accurate
science, so think
about it-- when you're
talking about lifetime
value, think about a range
or an interval of confidence.
Lastly, if you can,
the predictive models
might be useful, if
you have the data
and you have the capabilities.
Again, I'm not saying
don't use the other ones,
but just think about this, in
case you can actually run them.
And then fifth point
would be decide
in advance what are the
things that-- the cores,
the frequency, how frequent
are you going to calculate LTV.
And finally, make
sure that you try
to rely on metrics, and
then you, basically,
have things like
integrity of data,
and take the decisions
based on relevant samples.